[Musique]
une hotte des sons avec son projet
laboratoires osmose l'eau acime vue
comprendre ce qui plaît aux enfants
vivant avec un trouble du spectre de
l'autisme
je pense que ça leur donne un espace
pour être ce qu'ils sont ça leur permet
de s'exprimer de canaliser depuis
quelques mois des membres de leur caste
viennent régulièrement donner des
ateliers musicaux aux élèves de l'école
saint-etienne une pause musicale faite
sur mesure c'est d'être à l'écouté de ce
qu'ils sont et comment ils perçoivent
notre monde en fait c'est qu'avoir
effectivement des sanctions plus
difficile pour eux qui sont plus
stridents qui sont plus apaisant aussi
le langage musical universel mais il
faut prendre le temps de l'apprivoiser
un bonheur pour les élèves autant que
pour les musiciens qui a un contact
direct
parce que quand on est alors qu'est-ce
comme vous voyez que je te suis vraiment
vraiment loin vraiment proche de même
que les jeunes peuvent toucher mon
instrument
on ressent vraiment qu'on fait plaisir
[Musique]
où
important parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
familles qui ont déjà fait psa qui font
pas de sortie
tu peux aller à un concert je le sais
pas qu'on attende affaires vont réagir
parce que c'est trop fort les lumières
tout au pied serait ce que 5 minutes
lapd a dépensé beaucoup d'argent pour
rien l'orchestré présentera un grand
concert et spiri par les apprentissages
réalisés dans le cadre des ateliers
osmose mons rg je vois cela comme une
grande fête où on peut venir vraiment
comme on est et puis surtout en tant que
parent peut venir avec une famille où on
a un enfant t elle s'appuie en afin de
re typique et puis on est bien puis on
est en famille puis on partage quelque
chose de beau avec le sm en attendant le
cancer ces jeunes mélomanes repartent
avec de la musique plein les oreilles et
un grand sourire ici nabi alexandre
chartier à 2 canada morin